[MUSIC PLAYING]
IFAT YANAI: Hi, all.
Thanks for joining our session.
It's been an amazing week this
week here in San Francisco.
So before we will
start the session,
I'm happy to tell you a little
bit about DoIT International.
My name is Ifat Yanai and I'm a
partner manager at Google Cloud
based in Tel Aviv.
Part of my role is
to work with partners
like DoIT International and
help them to succeed and bring
the best out of Google Cloud
to our short customers.
DoIT International
was founded in 2010
by a small number of
software engineers
that actually understood
in the early stages
that App Engine, which is the
first Google Cloud product,
can bring lots of
value to startups
and help startup to focus
on the main business,
on sites, application, rather
than invest in maintenance
and infrastructure.
And since then, they did
lots of implementation
with many customers using
App Engine and, of course,
some other products and
leveraged the Google Cloud
solutions.
During the years,
DoIT International
became a global partner
of Google Cloud.
They are very active in
Israel, USA, and also Europe.
And they are doing lots of
projects, and implementation,
large-scale customers, and
bringing the best, as I said,
of Google Cloud
to our customers.
In addition to a great
professional services
and support to our customers,
DoIT are very active and
contribute to the open source
community by developing
lots of open-source tools.
Just go quickly on some of them
to get you a sense of examples.
One of them is Shamash,
which is a autoscaling
tool for manage
Hadoop and Spark,
Google manage Hadoop and Spark.
Another good example
is the Zorya,
which is a scheduler for--
forgot the word-- scheduler
for Compute Engine,
which can give customers,
actually, to use this product.
And it's an open
source, of course,
and sometimes reduce their
infrastructure cost up
to 60% of non-production
environment.
And the most famous
one is reOptimize.
ReOptimize is a open-sourced
tool, open-source platform
for cost optimization.
It is also available
in Google Marketplace.
And it helps
customers out to get
a better view of their workloads
and usage of their cloud
and the optimization
of their costs.
And there are so
many other tools,
and we will cover some of
them during the session.
And I'm happy now
to invite to stage
Vadim Solovey, who is the
founder of DoIT and the CTO.
Welcome, Vadim.
VADIM SOLOVEY: Thanks, Ifat,
for the great introduction.
I guess I couldn't
do better myself.
So hello, everyone.
We're going to have--
let me quickly catch
up here on things.
OK.
So during our session
today, I'm going
to tell you a customer story,
some mutual project that we
had together with a company
called Jelly Button.
So for these people
who do not know,
Jelly Button is
a gaming company.
They produce mobile games.
And one of the most famous
games is called "Pirate Kings."
So "Pirate Kings" have over
100 million active users
worldwide, people who play the
game on their iOS or Android
device.
And today we're going to talk
about how Jelly Button have
replaced their event analytics
pipeline based on the solution
that I'm going to
present you right now.
And it's not a big
secret that most people,
when they want to deploy some
sort of the event analytics
pipeline or platform,
they start with
the off-the-shelf products.
And there are so many available
solutions on the market,
products such as
Mixpanel or Segment
or even Google Analytics or
Kissmetrics and so many others.
And don't get me wrong.
All of those solutions
are excellent
and they definitely
have their own market.
However, this session
will focus on how
you can build your own
event analytics platform.
And why would you do
that, you may ask.
Well, usually it's because
the off-the-shelf platforms,
they won't be as
flexible as you'd like
or sometimes they
have a very high cost.
And the cost is usually
some sort of the per event
price that you pay.
Usually it's gradually
decreasing over volume,
like if you have more
events, you will probably
pay a little bit less.
However, at a certain
scale, the price
can go up as high as tens of
thousands of dollars per month.
And in that case, in
the Jelly Button case
specifically, they were spending
between $45,000 to $65,000
per month on their off-the-shelf
event analytics platform,
depending on the how
popular their game was
on a certain month.
And finally,
another problem that
usually exists with the
off-the-shelf solution,
is they don't allow
you to easily own
your own data,
meaning that making
it accessible and available
to your other systems
and services.
And for example, you can't use
your own BI tool of choice.
And you will have to use
the charting and reporting
engine that is a part of
the off-the-shelf tool.
And you can't give
your data analysts
an ability to query your
data using standard SQL.
And usually you will
need to use some sort
of a proprietary language.
And there are many
more examples why
those systems can be a little
bit limiting sometimes.
So for a couple of
years, Jelly Button
were using the off-the-shelf
analytics platform to the point
that it wasn't longer
financially feasible
and the flexibility
wasn't good enough.
So Jelly Button has decided
to build a new system,
and the design principle
of that new system
would be it has to be
flexible in the way
that it will allow
them to analyze
their data in any
way they would like
using standard SQL or
any BI tool of choice.
It should be cheap
to build, operate,
and maintain over time.
And it should have a
much better economy
of scale comparing to the
off-the-shelf solution
that they had.
And finally, it
has to be global.
Since there are players
anywhere in the world,
they wanted the events to be
sent with the lowest latency
possible.
And so based on all
of those design goals,
we came up with the following
high-level architecture
of their own event
analytics pipeline.
And let me walk you through this
architecture at the high level
before we are going to deep
dive into the specifics of each
and every part.
So first, we have
the ingestion part.
This is where we get the
event from mobile devices
and process them.
In general, there are two
distinct types of events.
One type are the events
being sent from the game
itself, from the mobile device.
For example, users logging
in, going from one level
to the other, or
accumulating stars
or doing in-app purchases.
Another kind of the event
are the events generated
by the gaming backend.
These are more
system-level events
and usually they
are good indicators
of the overall platform health.
The next big part
is event processing.
This is where we
validate the events,
parse them, store them
for future analysis.
This is also where we
calculate certain metrics,
such as leaderboards, or
in reaching the events
with the other data, such
as geolocation of users,
for example.
And finally, the last piece is
where we generate the reports
and allow the data scientists
to analyze the events.
So now lets take a closer look
at the event ingestion part.
So to ingest events, we need to
have some sort of the RESTful
API with which our mobile
SDK can communicate and sense
events.
And we have written an initial
version of our API, Node.js.
And we have decided to run
it on top of the Kubernetes
or specifically, GKE, which is
a Google-managed Kubernetes.
So you may ask why have we
choose GKE to run our API.
Well, we have considered
other options, such as Compute
Engine, for example.
But we wanted
something more managed
so we wouldn't be bothered
with things like autoscaling
or monitoring or doing version
upgrades of our software.
We have also
considered App Engine,
which is a Google Platform
as a service, which
we have used many,
many times in the past
for our other solutions.
However, App
Engine, as of today,
while it has some
really beautiful tools
for seamless deployments
and autoscaling,
it is a little bit limited to
only one geographical region.
And we wanted to have multiple
endpoints in many places
and in multiple geographies.
So finally, the
reason that we have
used GKE is because GKE
have gave us exactly the
features we needed--
fully managed
infrastructure on one hand,
but with an ability to
run multiple clusters
in different
regions, while being
able to deploy a single
version of our API.
And we are using features such
as horizontal pod autoscaling
to control the number
of API pods running,
according to the amounts
of the event per second
that we are getting.
And also the GKE
node autoscaler,
which automatically increases or
decreases the number of nodes,
as in accordance with
the amount of the pods
that we are running
at the same time.
And on top of that, we are also
using a really nice feature
called Cluster Federation.
So Cluster Federation
is essentially
a Kubernetes feature, which
gives you an ability to build,
I would like to say,
like, a supercluster.
So you can have a
multiple clusters.
Every cluster can be in a
different region or even
a different cloud
provider or on premises,
but you can still manage
all of those clusters
from a single control plane.
And it's a very powerful
feature, as you can imagine,
because I can have my
API running just anywhere
in the world, but still
controlling everything
from a single place.
And finally, the other
very important piece here
is the Google HTTPS
load balancer.
So we are using something
that's called Global IP, which
allow us to have a single
anycast IP address for our API.
And the request that is being
sent from the mobile device
is resolving that IP address
to the nearest location
that Google has in
the same region,
and that's done
automatically for you.
So initially, we had a couple of
clusters, one in North America
and the other one
in Western Europe.
But eventually, we have
added more clusters
in the other places as
well, just to cover them.
So to summarize that
point, we have a single IP.
All of the events are being
sent to that single IP.
The IP is being resolved
to a local cluster
in the region that is
geographically close to the end
user player.
And then the API processes the
event and pushes it forward.
So just to give
you a good example
of how having a local cluster
in certain geographies
improve the overall
latency, let's first
take a look on the median
latency for North America
or Western Europe.
So it's 89 milliseconds and
54 milliseconds for Europe.
However, as you can see,
for players in Asia-Pacific,
without the local
clusters there,
the latency was on a
scale of 250 milliseconds,
almost five times longer than
for players in geographies
where we have local clusters.
But thanks to the
Kubernetes Federation,
it was very easy for us to add
another cluster in Asia-Pacific
and that immediately
broke down the latency
to just 61 milliseconds, which
is almost 75% improvement.
And we didn't have
to change anything
to support this
additional cluster.
The IP of our API
stayed exactly the same,
thanks to the Global IP feature.
We didn't have to update
the mobile application just
because we added a new cluster.
And once we had the
cluster up and running
under the Federation,
the Kubernetes
pushed the latest
version of our API
to that cluster and the
Google HTTP load balancer
started to route any requests
coming from Asia-Pacific
to that new local cluster.
And as there will be more
players in other regions,
it will be as seamless for
us to add additional clusters
in the same way over time.
Another piece of technology
we are using here
is a Google Cloud Endpoints.
We obviously have to protect
the API from unauthorized use.
And we are using Cloud Endpoints
to provide additional features
that we just didn't
want to develop ourself
and rather prefer
to rely on Google.
So we are using Cloud
Endpoints to provide us
with the authentication,
rate control, and monitoring.
And let me put a little
bit more context here.
So of course,
authentication is important
because we don't want
unauthorized devices or bots
to send us ingenuine data.
And by using Cloud
Endpoints, we ensure
that only devices providing the
correct authentication token
can send us the event data.
Rate control is another very
important thing because even
while unauthenticated bots,
they cannot send the data
because they do
not have the token,
they can still make
attempts to send the data.
And if there is
enough of them, it
will be some sort of the
denial of service attack,
causing us to spend
extra money on more
resources such as
Kubernetes nodes or network
[INAUDIBLE] traffic.
And finally, Cloud
Endpoints provides
many additional features,
such as monitoring our API.
We can version the API.
And maybe most importantly,
it can automatically
generate the mobile SDK
for iOS and Android.
So once we introduce
a change to our API,
we can automatically
generate the SDK
and use that SDK in our
next version of the game.
Now that we are almost done
with the API part itself,
the final but very important
part is the Google Pub/Sub.
so in general, we are using
Pub/Sub to temporarily store
our event data that we are
getting from the devices.
Pub/Sub is a
managed message bus,
which essentially means
that we can create a topic.
Its a little bit
similar to, I would say,
water pipe, and then to send the
data from one side of that pipe
to the other side.
And in our case, we
are using Pub/Sub
because it's a good practice
to build systems in a way
where the communication between
different parts of our system
will be asynchronous.
In that way, we can scale the
different parts separately,
one from the other.
And also, if some part is
under load or a pressure
or even down, we are
not losing any data.
So we are getting the event from
the API running on Kubernetes
and we are putting that
event into the Pub/Sub.
So let's see what happens next.
So after the ingestion
part is done,
we are getting into
the event processing.
So what do I mean
by event processing?
Event processing its
actually many things
that we need or
have to do to allow
effective analysis of the data.
So first, we need
to parse the events
and then we need to make sure
they are complete and valid.
Usually, after that, we will
want to enrich our data.
For example, one of the
most popular enrichments
are geolocation based on the
IP address of the request.
We would like to know the
city, country, perhaps
some other data of the player.
And after enrichment, we
are grouping and aggregating
the data because
sometimes we would
like to store different
events in different tables
in our database.
I will get to that
a little bit later.
And we also want to calculate
some metrics on the fly.
So for example, think
of the leaderboard.
So we want to
display a leaderboard
on our website to see how
many stars every player has.
So one way of doing that
would be to store everything
in some database and then make
some queries over the data
and, let's say, refresh them
every minute or something.
What we are doing
here, we are actually
calculating the leaderboard
on the fly at the time
that we process the events.
And that's pretty cool, right?
So for event processing,
we are using Apache Beam.
It's an open-source
project originated
from Google several
years ago, and now it's
a part of Apache Foundation.
Or specifically, in our case,
we are using Google Cloud
Dataflow, which is a managed
version of the Apache Beam,
so we wouldn't need to worry
about deploying our own servers
or scaling them
or monitoring them
according to the volume of the
data that we are receiving.
And Google Cloud
Dataflow is basically
a cloud-based
version of the ETL,
of the Extract
Transfer Load paradigm.
And with Dataflow, we can read
the data from a certain source,
parse the data, transform
it, aggregate it, group it,
and, finally, send it
to another destination.
And you can write the Google
Dataflow pipelines or jobs
in Java or Python.
And it has a long
list of supported
connectors to various
Google Cloud products,
such as Pub/Sub or BigQuery or
Bigtable or Spanner or Cloud
SQL and so many others.
And if you'd like, you
can even use Apache Beam
and run your jobs
on external data
processing engines
such a Spark or Flink,
which means it gives you
the freedom of running
your workloads just anywhere
without any kind of a vendor
lock-in.
And this was something that
was very important for us
because we wanted
to give that freedom
to be able to basically run
it everywhere if so we choose.
So in our case, we
are reading the data
from the Google Pub/Sub.
We are parsing the data.
We are doing the
aggregation and groupings,
and finally sending the
data to the Google BigQuery
and Bigtable for
further analysis.
So the code that you
are seeing right now
is some kind of a pseudo
code because the actual code,
while it looks like very
similar, its a little bit
more verbose because Java is
a pretty verbose language.
So I just couldn't fit it
to put that on the slide,
but you get the idea.
And the Apache Beam SDK is
very powerful in the sense
that you can write a
very complicated code,
you can have a very
complicated pipeline,
but your code is very short.
And once you deploy your
code, the Google Dataflow
will automatically
build a graph,
which you can see on the
right side of the slide.
So that graph is being
automatically generated
from your code.
You will see that on
the Google Cloud console
along some monitoring
information
on how your pipeline
is performing, meaning,
for example, how many
events you are processing,
what is the delay of the
event or, in other words,
how much time does
it take to process
a single event from the second
it's being read from the Google
Pub/Sub until to the point that
it's being pushed to the Google
BigQuery.
And then you can
monitor those metrics
and build some sort
of alerts so you
can be notified if your
pipeline is performing
worse than you would expect.
And here is the actual
graph, by the way,
for the demo that we
will be showing shortly.
So in that graph,
you can see that we
are reading people data--
actually, it's information
about our users--
and the event data, which
are the actual events
like login or moving from
one level to the other.
And then we are doing the
parsing and aggregations
and essentially, finally,
we are pushing the data
to several destinations.
In our case, it's
BigQuery and Bigtable,
and I will get to that
in just one minute.
And since we are using streaming
pipelines with Apache Beam,
the time window notion is
extremely important here.
If you are constantly reading
the data from some streaming
source, such as Google
Pub/Sub for example,
and you want to build
aggregations on the fly,
time windows are essential
to be able to do that.
So Google Dataflow
will automatically
assign every event to
the correct time window
based on the semantic
event time, which
means the true time when
the event actually happened,
as opposed to the
time that event
was received by the Dataflow.
Now, if every part is in
the correct time window,
it is very simple to
count, for example,
to count the amount of
stars each player has
to calculate the
leaderboard and to update
that in the real time.
And there are many supported
window types in Google
Dataflow, for example,
fixed windows,
sliding windows,
session windows,
or even custom windows, if none
of the standard window types
doesn't work for you.
And windows are also
really helpful for taking
care of the late events.
For example, you can imagine
that you are playing the game,
but you are in the
elevator or you
are in the place where you have
a limited network coverage.
And in that case, even
if your mobile device
generates the
events, those events
are not being sent because
you don't have the network.
And sometimes it can
take a lot of time
to actually send those events.
It can be minutes.
It can be even hours
sometimes, if you
are taking flight for example.
And one of the greatest things
with the Google Dataflow
or Apache Beam in that
sense is that have
the notion of the late events.
So while the event
can really arrive late
by any amount of
time, it can still
be assigned to the
correct window,
to the correct time
window, so we can correctly
recalculate our leaderboards
at every given time.
And there are many innovations
available with Apache Beam 2.x.
The latest version is 2.5.
And those features, for example,
are dynamic destinations.
They can help you to send
your data to various tables
based on the arbitrary
data that you are receiving
or, for example, automatic
schema detections making
your life so much easier
by not having to hard code
your schemas into the code, into
the pipeline code that you're
producing.
And the other really
important part
here is the data mutability.
So the data mutability,
as it sounds,
it means that some data
can change over time.
And this may be a
little bit difficult
with analytical databases, such
as Google BigQuery, which are
append only by their nature.
But what if you have
a table of the players
and you want to update
the player information,
for example, on the fly?
Well, you may want
to update each player
with its current status of the
amount of stars that they have
or their cash balance.
And this is why we have
opted to use both Google
BigQuery for immutable data,
data that doesn't change
such as events, with Bigtable
for the mutable data,
such as player table.
And using Google
Cloud Dataflow, we
are sending those events
directly to the BigQuery,
making its available for later
analysis by data scientists
and our BI tools.
And for those people
who doesn't know,
Bigtable is a NoSQL
database powering
some really popular
applications, such as Gmail
or AdWords here at Google.
And it's ideal for storing
sparse information,
such as in our example,
people's profiles.
And it can support millions
of updates every second.
Bigtable is managed,
which means,
once again, we don't need to
be bothered with the management
by ourself.
And now that we are done
with the event processing,
let's talk a little bit
about the event analytics.
So for event analytics,
as you can imagine,
we are using Google BigQuery.
So this is a high level of
the BigQuery architecture.
One of the greatest
things about the BigQuery
is that it has storage and
compute scaled independently
on demand.
It helps us to analyze
billions of daily events
using standard SQL
at a great speed.
Most of our queries are
running only a few seconds,
despite the fact that they
scan terabytes of data.
And since last year,
Google BigQuery
allows you not only to
query native tables,
but also for the
federated tables.
And federated tables,
it means that they
can reside on other storage
systems such as Bigtable,
for example.
And since Bigtable itself
is a NoSQL database,
it means you cannot run
complex queries on it.
However, with Google BigQuery
and federated tables,
you can have the power of
both Bigtable and BigQuery
by being able to run the
really complicated SQL
queries over NoSQL data.
And if you can still remember
the beginning of my talk--
I barely can myself--
you may recall that we wanted
the event analytics platform
to be very cost effective.
And I also said that the
off-the-shelf solution
that Jelly Button were
using had a significant cost
over the tens of thousands
of dollars every month.
So let's take a short
look on how much
does it cost us today
to run the system
that I have just presented.
So we are using reOptimize.io
for Google Cloud Analytics.
It's available from DoIT
International for free.
It's a pretty sophisticated tool
that have some cost analytics
and cost optimization platform.
And what you can see
here on the slide
is one of the cost
control dashboards.
And so you can see how
much we are spending
on Google Cloud every
month and some breakdown
by specific product over time.
So in July, 2017, when we
launched the new system,
we were processing about
1.3 billion of daily events
and the overall cost
of the Google Cloud
for us was on the scale
of $1,500 per month.
That's all.
In January, 2018, we were
ingesting and processing
3.3 billion events--
it's about three times more--
and our cost was just
about $2000 per month.
And finally, during May,
2018, just a few months ago,
we were already
processing 6 million--
6 billion, I'm sorry,
of daily events.
And still is our cost a
little bit less than--
well, actually, a little
bit more than $3,000.
So if you compare that
to the $45,000 to $65,000
that we were paying
every month before that,
that's a pretty significant
cost saving, right?
You can clap.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you, guys.
So it took us about five
weeks of three people
to build the new system.
We have spent about
two weeks exploring
different architectures
and prototyping
before we could settle on
the current state of affairs.
Then we took another week to
make our code production-ready,
another week of testing
everything in parallel
to running the previous system.
And finally, over the
course of the fifth week,
we have gradually moved all
of our event analytics traffic
to the new system.
And right now I
would like to call
Yoram, a customer
reliability engineer at DoIT
International for the demo.
[APPLAUSE]
YORAM BEN-YAACOV:
Thank you [INAUDIBLE]..
Thank you, Vadim.
Hi, everybody.
So we're all familiar with
the common flow in which data
is coming to Pub/Sub.
And from there, we
take it using Dataflow,
doing whatever we
want to do with it,
and putting it into BigQuery.
Since this is the
[INAUDIBLE] I'm
going to show a little bit about
what we are doing with Bigtable
and why is it more dynamic
and more interesting.
So as Vadim said,
last year Google
announced the federated
queries, which
allows you to run SQL queries
on unstructured data that
reside on Bigtable.
This allows us to run the same
SQL queries on virtual tables
on BigQuery that actually
belongs to Bigtable.
So what we got
was two requests--
were two requests in
the latest version.
The first one was to create
a dynamic leaderboard
for bigger amount
of users, something
that will not be
calculated in Dataflow,
but will be taken outside.
And the second thing
was to be able to remove
a user from the system
according to the GDPR compliance
with the GDPR guidelines.
To solve this, we decided
to actually put Bigtable
into the flow and to split the
data according to the need.
So we have three types of data.
We have the users,
which contains the PII.
We have the events, which
doesn't contain any PII,
and the leaderboard, again,
doesn't contain any PII.
So this is as part,
very small part
of the pipeline in Dataflow.
I just want you to see a little
bit about what we are doing.
We actually have two main flows.
We have the one on the left
that actually takes data
from people, messages that are
coming to the people in topic
on Pub/Sub.
It's doing all kind
of fancy enrichments.
It depends, again, on the
game and the requirements.
And from there
directly to Bigtable.
Let's see a little bit about
what we have on Bigtable.
So actually, on Bigtable,
we have two tables.
We have the leaderboards
and we have the people.
Now, if I want to
see one of the users,
for example, on Bigtable,
then I will probably
do something like
this and I will get
all the history of the user.
To the people who don't
know, Bigtable actually
gives us kind of
three-dimensional table.
So we have not only the
columns and the family names,
we also have the time
period, a time series
of data per each row.
But this is not something
which is that easy to utilize.
So what we did was actually
to define the same table using
this JSON, to take this JSON,
and to put it into Bigtable
and defined a federated extended
table, the BigQuery table.
Sorry, the Bigtable
table on BigQuery.
I have too many bigs
and too many tables.
My apologies.
Sorry.
You have to do
something about it.
So actually, this is the
schema of the people table
that reside on Bigtable as
it represent on BigQuery.
Now, from here, if I
want to do the same query
on the same user,
it's relatively easy.
And of course, I
can see in one line
who is the user, what
is his age, gender.
Again, I defined
over here that I
want to see only the latest
version of each of the columns.
Since it's a sparse
data, I will get
only the relevant
data that exist,
the latest version over here.
So I want to go back to
the second flow and--
now, the second flow is actually
the more interesting one,
the way I see it, because
the second flow takes
all the messages that
are event-related.
So it lists them to a
different topic on Pub/Sub.
It takes all the data, all
the messages that arrive,
and it will do four things
with these messages.
The first one, store the
row message into BigQuery.
And I did make a mistake over
here, directly to BigQuery.
This is actually the
single source of truth.
The customer can do whatever
analytics on the BigQuery
using the BigQuery engine.
It will run fast
and it will have
all the advantages of BigQuery.
The second part of the flow will
take the event, the same event.
Now we will do some kind,
again, of any fancy enrichment
and it will update or
actually insert new records
into two tables.
The first one is to
the people table.
This way, I don't have to
calculate outside of Bigtable
the status of each user once
I entered new row on new value
for each of these,
the stars and cash.
The user will automatically will
have only the latest version
that we entered.
The second thing
is the leaderboard.
Now, when I'm doing
this I actually
don't need Bigtable to
handle all the windowing
and splitting and keeping
the late arrivals.
Not only that, when I'm doing
windowing on Dataflow that I
need to define a
windows, time periods,
early firing over here, the
data is up to date all the time.
Again, we are utilizing
the very fast response,
the millisecond of some
millisecond response
of Bigtable.
So let's look a bit
into the tables.
So what we did was to
take the leaderboard--
I want to start, first of all,
with the more trivial one,
which is the immutable events.
Again, this is a very standard
BigQuery table, native BigQuery
table, I'm sure that
you're all familiar with.
So I will continue to the next
one, which is the leaderboard.
This is the one that
is more interesting.
This is the table that exists
physically on Bigtable,
but we represented
it using this JSON.
This is very small
JSON of I want
to know only the star balance
and the cash balance per user.
The key that we used
over here was actually
the date and the user ID.
Now, if I want to query
for a specific date,
I want to see-- let's say I
want to see who are the five
leaders for the--
it's not for the 24th
because I just changed the
query today to the 25th.
So as you can see,
I have the key.
From the key I got the user
ID and I know exactly how much
star balance and cash balance.
In this case, I ordered it
according to the star balance
because usually this
is what we care.
Now, if somebody from marketing,
for example, or from sales
want to better understand
who are the best spenders
or leaders for a
period of time, I
can always go and also do the
row between, and then give
a date range or a key range.
And according to this key
range, get all the relevant data
that reside inside this range.
In this case, I did from
the 22nd till today.
And I got a different
list of people.
This time they are sorted
by the cash balance.
Now again, think about the fact
that all this data actually
resides in Bigtable.
This is something that
was not possible using
CBT or any other common
tools working with Bigtable.
But once we are working with
BigQuery and federated tables,
I can do this
without any problem.
Now, the last thing
that we still have
is how we remove the user.
So again, doing it with BigQuery
was a bit more complicated.
Here, if I have this user,
all I have to do is delete row
and that's it.
And hopefully, the gods of
demo will not do anything.
And yes, he's out.
One last thing before I finish.
Vadim spoke about part
of the flow that we did.
This is to date the [INAUDIBLE],,
which is one of the operations
that we are speaking about,
that we presented earlier.
So we can play with it and get
80% to 90% of the flow already.
That's it.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
VADIM SOLOVEY: Thanks, Yoram.
So just one thing before
we end the session today.
So if you are like
Jelly Button and you
are looking to build your own
event analytics pipeline based
on the principles that we
explained during that session,
we have some great news.
After implementing that
analytics pipeline solution
for many other customers
in the last year,
we have decided to
open-source that.
So you have the whole solution
and the whole blueprint
publicly available
on the GitHub.
So its kind of like
opinionated, based
on our experience
as best practices,
event analytics pipeline
supporting elastic schemas.
And you can get going
just in a couple of hours.
So just clone the
repository and, of course,
fill the issue if
you need some help.
And well, some references--
you will get them, I guess, when
you access that presentation
on the Google website.
But there are some
useful resources
that we thought it would be
great sharing them with you.
Ifat?
IFAT YANAI: So
thank you very much,
Vadim and Yoram, for
a great presentation.
And I hope you all enjoy it.
And one last thing I
wanted to say about DoIT--
I don't know if you all are
aware, but during this week
here in San Francisco,
we had a partner summit
and DoIT won third time in
a row in the global award
for its sales and
engineering excellence.
So I think they deserve
applause for that as well.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]